Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher:
Write a movie that you love, that is why
we go to see movies where the movie just
hits you in the heart and you're like
Oh my god! That movie is great,
even if it's Pretty Woman.
Film Courage: How do you search for those
beautiful moments in the midst of tragedy?
Tony: I find the tragedy first. I
think the tragedy is what guts me.
Then I try to find meaning in the
tragedy, meaning in my tragedies
and it's hard to find meaning in the tragedy.
Since Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk, I've
written two other books where I
went even deeper into tragedies and
one I checked myself into an outpatient hospital
program because I was suicidal. I've had to learn
to pick my tragedies and then also give them
time I think. I wasn't giving my tragedies
enough time. But the beauty of tragedy is we
all have tragedies. We connect on it and I think
as humans we connect more on not just the
tragedy but how we got out of the tragedy.
Even in film it's like you put your character
into conflict then we want to know how are
they going to get out of the conflict? How are
they getting out of that little tragedy moment
in a scene and then that's what shows character
building. I feel like we're character building
around each other when we do have tragedies
in our lives, when we can we find our ways
to pull out of it and then survive and then go
Wait a second, okay how does this work for me
in being with other people and then other people?
Then other people it's just the beauty of Oh yeah
I've been through that. You just you hear someone
goes Oh yeah, now I've been through that I get it
that's all you need and you're like ah and
there's just instant camaraderie with tragedy
which is sad I don't know why we need tragedy
and we all just can't be joyful buddhas but for
some odd reason tragedy and suffering I think is
in the theme of our lives and our existence so
when we put it on the page then we get to see
our protagonist get into the tragedy get into
the conflict whatever the conflict is the conflict
could be the protagonist wants to ask the woman of
his dreams out on a date you know or it could be
the protagonist is being riddled by bullets and
they're trying to dive and they're in the trenches
and as far as the film is concerned and the
conflict's concerned the stakes are the same
and as far as what the characters internal
tragedy is happening I like to you even even when
I have students who are writing romantic comedies
they apologize for it I'm sorry I'm like don't
apologize and I was like watch mob movies watch
mob movies and and and as you look at the beats
of the conflict of the mob movies it's very simple
because there's a lot of hierarchy involved and
then bring it over to your romantic comedy and
you can add those beats in and keep those stakes
just as high as the mob film and but it's but
it'll be under the guise of a you know romantic
comedy and the greatest you know the the fun
comedy vibe a lot of it comes from a tragedy or a
tragic place and that's when it's even more funny
yeah so that's great do you have certain movies
you recommend one romantic comedy versus one mob
movie oh that would be yeah I wish I had those
I well I watched that tv series Gamora recently
The Italian I think it was The Italian one but as
for mob movies you know I’ll tell them to watch I
you know I spoke ahead I don't have I'm not a I
don't have a good I don't have a good knowledge
of romantic comedies or mob movies but one one
movie I bring up a lot in class and it drives
some people nuts is swingers I think that was
1996 with Jon Favreau and Vince Vaughn and
they're a group of friends and you know
Jon Favreau's character his name is mike
and he's the protagonist and he's trying to
get over his girlfriend that he's trying to
get over heartbreak he's trying to make it in
la but mainly he's trying to get over heartbreak
and everyone in the movie just wants to help
him get over heartbreak but if you really watch
the movie and you watch the dialogue that's
happening they are fighting the whole time
it's almost like they're about to come to blows
with their dialogue but they all want the same
thing they just want Mikey to feel better Mikey
just get over your girl your ex-girlfriend but
they're they're it's a constant push and pull
and it's funny and it's sad and so when this
when they're br when the point of view of each
character is bringing in that high of stakes
to the same goal that's when you
know it's if it's it's it's a tragedy
to watch the movie the whole movie is a
tragedy but it's hilarious because everyone's
the angle they're fighting at is just
funny sure sure I think there's some in
Moonlight and Mystic Pizza there's a lot of
dialogue that's very similar to that too whether
it might be loving but they're yelling and and
sort of it is like rapid fire with the dialogue
and yeah that's and that's when it's beautiful
and that's when we connect because we wait you
know it's like we want we want the character to
win you know it's like how is the character going
to win how are they going to get there and then
we almost you know when when they're when there's
heavy conflict on the screen it's almost like
they start to go into a situation we're like no
don't go there okay if you go there you better
do blank blank and blank and of course they're
not going to do that because we want to keep the
movie going another five minutes so it can't be
resolved yet they need to get more sand in their
eyeballs before they get to the next scene so
why do you think your students feel they have
to apologize or some of them feel they have to
apologize for wanting to write romantic comedies I
don't know you know it's I think people apologize
for genre sometimes and and I'm just like don't
apologize it's every story means something
no matter what you're doing and it's and it's what
you love you know just was write the movies that
write a movie that you love that is why do we
go to see movies and you and where's movie just
hits you in the heart and you're like oh my god
that movie is great even if it's pretty woman
but if that's what gets you if that's what stirs
your soul there's a reason for it write that
right don't write that movie but write write
the write the general idea and the general theme
in that movie right you know write the Meg Ryan
Tom Hanks movie it's it's all just it's I think
maybe there's a there's a pressure for like oh is
it Oscar-worthy oh with this would Meryl Streep
be cast in this and it's just like no write
write your truth write what's important to you
and that's going to make the best movie that
you can make now you know never write towards
something that you just feel like is a good idea
you know that's that everyone's on and on about
remember the movie Foxes I don't oh okay it
has Scott Baio, Jody Foster, Sally Kellerman
and is from the Runaways Cherie Curie oh my god
okay so and it's the one of these movies where
it just doesn't leave you and so it's one of
these things where you would say it and people
go oh you like that movie but there shouldn't be
anything wrong with liking a movie yes it calls
to you I totally agree and I don't like it when
people dirt on other people for liking something
right that just irks me to no end and I and I
think that doesn't lead to more conversation
that leads to a stop and so you know if it doesn't
matter what people like it's fun it's as it's you
know don't it's like you know and I come from
the music a college radio music dj which was
the snotty is the snottiest in the 1990s and I was
that jerk and like so they started to realize wait
just because someone doesn't know sonic youth or
the acoustics doesn't mean that they're inferior
humans you know or maybe they don't like a certain
thing like even the you know it's if they don't
like something it's fun to find out why that's
the that's the why don't you like that or why do
you like that wait you know I i found a I found a
backstreet boys song for a project I was working
on and I'm like this is perfect and I you know I
know everyone's there's gonna be a lot of people
that are going why is tony putting a backstreet
boys song in there but but it's just like
it's just perfect and if someone wants to go
see the backstreet boys just let them let them
enjoy their experience I don't like it when
people try to crush people's experiences if
they want to see Meg Ryan and Tom Hanks possibly
get together great why why do you like that movie
that's that's that we should be passionate about
it because every life's hard enough as it is so
you know taking a crap on people's taste is
kind of the last thing we need to do let's
try to find out why they like a certain thing
that's where the fun stories are as far as I'm
concerned yeah I agree I agree I think people
should whether it's music or books or or film
yeah you should be entitled to if we want to watch
a real cheesy movie and enjoy it and or even have
it playing in the background all the time there's
something that calls to us I use Ocean's 11 a lot
in my this is the Solderberg I always say his name
wrong up I said it right that time his his remake
but that movie's gorgeous as far as
a heist movie and all the elements of
storytelling and I actually I’ll watch it for
fun sometimes and people kind of are just like
you know it's like oh yeah well that top 40 movie
what are you talking about and I'm like no there's
actually there's a lot of great scenes in there
that i'll bring to class and show the dynamics of
and just the dialogue and the dialogue is tight
and those actors are all top-notch actors yeah
some of them are superstars that's fine but they
are great at what they do and there's a reason why
most of them are superstars it's because
they've worked really hard to get there.